[Music]
do
[Music]
now in so far as the self-certain spirit
as a beautiful soul does not possess the
power to renounce the knowledge of
itself which it keeps to itself
it cannot attain to an identity with a
consciousness that is repulsed nor
therefore to a vision of the unity of
itself in the other
cannot attain to an objective existence
consequently the identity comes about
only negatively as a being devoid of
spirit
the beautiful soul lacking in actual
existence
entangled in the contradiction between
its pure self and the necessity of that
self
to externalize itself and change itself
into an actual existence
and dwelling in the immediacy of this
firmly held antithesis
and immediacy which alone is the middle
term reconciling the antithesis
which has been intensified to its pure
abstraction
and his pure being or empty nothingness
this beautiful soul then being conscious
of this contradiction in its
unreconciled immediacy
is disordered to the point of madness
wastes itself in yearning
and pines away in consumption there
thereby it does in fact surrender the
being for self to which it so stubbornly
clings
but what it brings forth is only the
non-spiritual unity
of mere being
paragraph 668 is entirely
focused on this this figure this gestalt
shape of consciousness of the beautiful
soul and
we can see how it's essentially a dead
end
and the beautiful soul is a notion that
we've already encountered several times
in this section
is the consciousness that prides itself
on
what it thinks itself to be but doesn't
act
doesn't make itself actual veer clique
it doesn't doesn't do
what the other which it calls the evil
consciousness the individual the acting
consciousness
it doesn't do what that consciousness
does
and it views itself as being better
as having a certain purity to itself and
now
we end up seeing why this really doesn't
amount to anything and ultimately leads
to what he what he calls
the non-spiritual unity of mere
being so he tells us this self-certain
spirit which is what this entire section
has been about right as a beautiful soul
does not possess the power to renounce
the knowledge of itself
which it keeps to itself now what is
that knowledge of itself which it
keeps to itself well the knowledge
of its own condition remember that in
the
passages just prior to this there was
kind of a breakthrough on the side of
the other
the evil consciousness confessed its
evil
and it was left waiting for the other
one just like somebody holding up a high
five
waiting for the other person to clap the
hand and you're like what's going on
here
instead the the beautiful soul retreated
into itself into its own superiority and
didn't acknowledge its own fault
in this so it says it cannot attain to
an identity with the consciousness it
has repulsed pushed away rejected
nor to a vision of the unity of itself
in the other and
we should you know make a few remarks
about terms here
so the identity is is glycite
and yes that could be identity that
could also be
equivalents that could also be in this
case
actually we're going to talk in a few
paragraphs about reciprocity
it's not attaining that the other was
ready to
give that and say oh man you know i'm a
sinner i screw up i
i went off on my own and did what i what
i did you know my action isn't
completely just beautiful noble whatever
you're like that too i assume right and
then the the beautiful soul said no no
you're assuming wrong
uh it's you that's that's the problem so
it's not able to attain
what here miller is translating his
identity with it
you might say a being able to be in in
connection with it
and it's not able to have a unity
einheit with it
either he's going to use this term
identity again right almost immediately
after that
it cannot uh identity comes about only
negatively as a being devoid
of spirit so this is a very interesting
idea
before that though he says it cannot
attain to an objective
existence now the german text does not
actually say
objective or gegensten leak or anything
like that
it just says dozen so miller is
kind of reading that in but that's okay
because
this is heading in that direction
of you know this this particular sense
of objective and so what do we have over
here we have all of these
these sort of complexes within the
beautiful soul
so he goes on and he says
the identity comes about negatively the
beautiful
soul lacking an actual existence now
what does it what does it mean to lack
an actual
existence a veer clique right out in the
world
engaged with things so the beautiful
soul how does it lack
an actual existence this person does
exist
they have a body they're in the world
they're engaged
you know in all sorts of things with
others they put on their pants or
whatever else they're wearing
and go out in town and chit chat with
people otherwise you can't be a
beautiful soul really
you can't just be a beautiful soul
entirely locked in your own head
but there is a difference between words
and action there is a difference between
thought and action there isn't
a difference between intentions not
carried out
so an ineffective will and the will that
produces
action he goes on and he says
it's entangled in a contradiction so
there's a
contradiction gagging that's uh between
its its uh pure self and the necessity
of that self note bendy kite right to
externalize itself to
to make itself outer right to go out
into the world
and change itself into an actual
existence
and the kind of actual existence that
the other has already done as a matter
of fact you could say
problem with the others get too much of
that actual existence wouldn't it be
nice if the beautiful soul
could do that so he says dwelling
in the immediacy of this firmly held
antithesis so
what do we mean by the immediacy you
know when mitchell barkite
can be understood as um you know
it's treating it as a given right
as something that's just taken for
granted
and not really questioned it can also be
understood as
the lack of mediation and
what was the opportunity for mediation
talking with the other
it rejected the overtures the advances
the confession of the other
that could have provided a kind of
mediation for itself instead it has this
immediacy and he says this immediacy is
the middle term
the the means the connection reconciling
the antithesis which has been
intensified
to its pure abstraction and his pure
being or empty nothingness
this beautiful soul being conscious of
this contradiction
right so the the beautiful soul is
really
i mean there's content there but it
really could be any any content
whatsoever it's just something where
somebody is saying i'm the good person
i'm the
the right person i'm the person who
has whatever it is that we're counting
as essential
important and that makes me the kind of
person who i am
you know in some ages it might be being
a a decadent bohemian in some ages it
might be making a ton of money and being
a thought leader or whatever it's going
to be right any of those could be the
beautiful soul
as a matter of fact we could come up
with example after example after example
in our own time
of all sorts of modalities of beautiful
souls
so is is it really reconciled
hagel says no because the next thing he
says is that this
uh it's conscious of this contradiction
in its unreconciled immediacy
so it it wants things to be you know
harmonized within itself but it's not
so he goes on and he says it's
disordered to the point of madness
wastes itself away in yearning
pines away in consumption thereby it
does in fact surrender the being for
self to which it stubbornly clings what
it brings forth
is only the non-spiritual unity of mere
being it doesn't really understand
itself
and it missed the opportunity
to grow in relation to the other
and the action of the other by some sort
of reciprocal
meeting at halfway or counteraction
it missed its opportunity and now it's
kind of shut up in itself in its own
discourse about
how cool or great or beautiful it is
the true that is the self-conscious and
existent equalization of the two sides
is necessitated by
and already contained in the foregoing
the breaking of the hard heart and the
raising of it to universality
is the same movement which was expressed
in the consciousness that made
confession of itself
the wounds of the spirit heal and leave
no scars behind
the deed is not imperishable it is taken
back by spirit into itself
and the aspect of individuality present
in it whether it is intention or as an
existent negativity and limitation
straightaway vanishes the self that
carries out the action
the form of its act is only a moment to
the whole and so likewise is the
knowledge that by its judgment
determines and establishes the
distinction between the individual
and universal aspects of the action the
evil consciousness referred to
above posits as externalization of
itself or posits itself as a moment
being enticed into openly confessing
itself by the vision of itself in the
other
but just as the former has to surrender
its one-sided unacknowledged existence
of its particular being for self
so too must this other set aside it's
one-sided unacknowledged judgment
just as the former exhibits the power of
spirit over its actual existence
so does this other exhibit the power of
spirit over the specific notion
of itself
in paragraph 669 we now see a
shift to focusing on the
acting consciousness as opposed to the
judging
consciousness the individual versus the
universal
but there is a walk-on who doesn't
actually like push all the other actors
off of the stage but certainly draws the
central attention and that is geist or
spirit who's going to be incredibly
important throughout the rest of this
section in the few paragraphs that are
left
now it would be tempting to misread
what is going on here as really being
about the
the universal judging consciousness
because
there's this reference to the hardened
heart
right and just a few paragraphs earlier
in fact uh this is just two paragraphs
earlier
the last sentence of 667 is
by this hardness of heart you know so
it's true that there is a hardened heart
on the side of the universal
consciousness that's what allowed it to
say screw you i don't actually want to
confess anything on my side after the
the acting consciousness confessed
itself
but what's what's actually going on here
there was a hardened heart in the past
on the side
of the acting consciousness when it said
i'm going to act and i'm not going to
wait for you to like tell me what's what
but eventually it relented and so its
heart and heart has
already been broken and
you could say the the sign of that but
also
the modality of that took place through
this
confession that it made to the
universal consciousness also to itself
and now as we're seeing to spirit
uh in a broader sense the community so
he says
the true equalization of the two sides
is necessitated by and already contained
in the foregoing
so you know earlier we saw
just in the last paragraph there was no
like height there was no
identity now we have an ausglyc
nung right a reckoning in a way or a
equivalency that's being produced an
equalization
they're being brought into connection
with each other and it's not because
of what the universal consciousness was
doing because the universal
consciousness is being kind of a jerk
throughout this and it's not just on the
side of what the
individual consciousness did there's
something bigger going on
so he says this is a self-conscious
and existent equalization those are very
important it's self-conscious
as it's realized to be the case it's
also of
self-consciousnesses which are related
to each other
remember the old lesson from very early
on self-consciousness
exists through another
self-consciousness or it has its
being its existence its actuality
its identity so he says that the
breaking of the hard heart
and the raising of it to universality
is the same movement which was expressed
in the consciousness that made
confession of itself
this breaking of the heart heart raised
it to universality
it is no longer just an individual
it is an individual who recognizes that
as an individual they're part of
something
bigger and that they don't have their
meaning just in themselves they can't
just follow their natural or egoistic
desires or urges they need to identify
with something
more now what what that more is is going
to depend on
you know the shape of consciousness the
community we don't have to worry too
much about that
at this point so he goes on and he says
the wounds of the spirit heal and leave
no scars behind
this is a very famous phrase and i do
want to specify something here
we must always remember that this is a
dialectic
which means two things there is a
developmental process that's taking
place which is
complex and in which the two sides or
more than two sides sometimes can't get
away from each other
and have to transform we must also
remember
that this is not inevitable hegel's
writing
the book as if well this is the natural
course that things follow
for every dialectical progression that
makes it to this point
and then has the wounds of the spirit
heal without any scars
there are probably dozens scores
thousands of similar processes
that never make it that far there are
wounds of the spirit
that have not yet healed this is the
case of
you know this you might say this is kind
of a special case
reconciling all this together so he says
the deed is not imperishable it's taken
back by spirit into itself
and the aspect of individuality present
in it
whether as an intention what what the
person was aiming at
or as an existent negativity and
limitation straight away vanishes now
what are we talking about there what
would be an existent negativity and
limitation
the fact that you attempt something and
fail
the fact that you don't have the
resources that you need or don't find
the
gripping point or response
the fact that your plans are well
intended but
not particularly well executed the
failings that we call a weakness
of will or inability to persevere
all of those sorts of things are on the
side of the individual
as are their intentions they're taken
up as universal into what we're calling
spirit here you call this the
mind of the community and this happens
all the time you know think about how we
teach historical figures
and what they were up to a great example
of this
would be you know martin luther king
it was recently martin luther king day
so we had all these people trotting out
their little quotes and sound bites and
pictures of the guy you know saying oh
we've got to all learn to be
you know brothers and sisters to each
other and get along and get past racism
and that that is something that he was
all about
but there was so much more to his action
and
we overlook the fact that many of the
people praising him today would actually
have hated him back then and said
you know they would they would have been
the racists or the white moderates
or the people saying oh you're you're
too radical or
any of those sorts of things in a way in
in a cheapened sense
this illustrates what we're talking
about here
with how he's been recuperated and we
forget about the fact that
you know he he was in fact
originally he was not devoted to
non-violence he was actually
you know devoted to self-defense and
then changed his mind
afterwards through thinking reading
confronting and he stuck to it right
those are the things that we can
focus on if we want a better sense of of
the action
we can think about all sorts of other
people as well as prime examples of this
so like he says the aspect of
individuality
vanishes the self that carries out the
action the form of its act is only a
moment of the whole
so likewise is the knowledge that by its
judgment
determines and establishes the
distinction between the individual and
universal aspects of the action
so the evil consciousness posits this
externalization of itself
or posits itself as a moment being
enticed into openly confessing itself
by the vision of itself in the other who
is the other the universal judging
consciousness this is the
dynamic that we saw just a few
paragraphs back
right and he goes on he says just as the
former and who's the former the the evil
consciousness
has to surrender its one-sided
unacknowledged existence of its
particular being for self
so too must this other the beautiful
soul
set aside its one-sided unacknowledged
judgment and so what is spirit doing
it's taking the individual action the
deed
the tot right also the action in the
sense of comportment handling
there's an externalization that has to
take place here that externalization
produces a wound
every externalization produces a wound
within the spirit from this hegelian
perspective
but it's a wound that can heal without
any
scar without what does it mean to have a
scar
some people like scars because they're
like an emblem of something oh
man look at what i went through you know
like i think about my scars
i've got a scar here from when i was uh
young and stupid and
was breaking boxes with my bare hands
and there was a steel bar in there
and i got cut on it and taken to the
hospital and they stitched up and you
can still
see it there right and i could like say
oh my battle wound you know i'm a tough
guy
right or i could talk about the brand
that i have on my hand of a
cross that we burned into our hands when
i was young and stupid
as a blood brother thing that's still
there very very hard to see
so scars can be markings but scars
also inhibit they
reduce mobility they give you problems
later on you know like this one
things never completely healed up right
and i still get pains
in here from time to time and the skin
doesn't stretch
as well so healing with no scar
means a sort of fluidity and
adaptability that that's quite important
to bring this to a close look at the
last thing that he says
just as the former exhibits the power of
spirit
over its actual existence right spirit
is mastering what the the evil
individual consciousness is doing the
person who actually
exists it's also exhibiting the power of
spirit over the specific
notion of itself in
the beautiful soul so this this term
notion is going to be
quite important the grief the concept
this has a self-concept because it
doesn't actually have any action
and now we have to see where we go after
this
the latter however renounces the
divisive thought and the
hard-heartedness of the being for self
which clings to it because it has in
fact
seen itself in the first this first
consciousness which turns its back on
its actual existence and makes itself
into a superseded particular
consciousness thereby displays itself as
in fact a universal it returns from its
external actual existence back into
itself as essential being
and therein the universal consciousness
thus recognizes itself
the forgiveness which it extends the
other is the renunciation of itself
of its unreal essential being which it
put on a level with that other which was
a real action
and acknowledges that what thought
characterized as bad
that is action is good or rather it
abandons this distinction
of the specific thought in its
objectively determined judgment
just as the other abandons its
subjective characterization of action
the word of reconciliation is the
objectively existent spirit which
beholds the pure knowledge of itself qua
universal existence in its opposite in
the pure knowledge of itself
qua absolutely self-contained and
exclusive individuality
a reciprocal recognition which is
absolute
spirit
in paragraph 670 we we
finally see a decent response
on the part of the universal judging
consciousness
which allows hegel to talk in the end
of a reciprocal recognition gag and
zeitgeist
that is absolute spirit and
you know you could say this is really
happening late in the game
there's actually not that much
development going on here and
you know at the risk of saying that the
spirit section could have been
prolonged you almost wish that he'd said
a bit more
about just what's happening on the side
of the universal
judging consciousness because the
reconciliation happens
so quickly after so much work on the
side of the individual acting
consciousness so he says the latter
which is the universal judging
consciousness
renounces this divisive thought
and the hard-heartedness of the being
for self which clings to it
because it has in fact seen itself
in the first in in the other
consciousness and this is an advance
this is
it realizes something and remember that
the
way in which the individual acting
consciousness was able to overcome its
own hard-heartedness
and to confess itself make the overture
to the universal judging consciousness
which then was repulsed
by it was by seeing its own self in
in the other and this there's something
really central and important here
so he says that this first consciousness
which turns back
on its actual existence and makes itself
into a
superseded that is alpha hobana right
a particular consciousness a decent
a this right thereby displays itself in
as in fact a universal so it displays
darstelling right
it sets itself out there it puts itself
out there literally
for the other and for itself for the
world
as a universal and this
goes back to the previous paragraph
where we saw that the
individuality of the action is in some
respects superseded
you know the wounds of the spirit
created by action
heal without scars but something else is
happening here he says it returns from
its
external actual existence it's very
clique does i'm
right in back into itself as an
essential being as a reason
as something that is important that
holds our attention
now here's where the other consciousness
now does something he says therein
the universal consciousness thus
recognizes itself with this recognition
on air cannon it is recognizing itself
it's recognizing by looking at the other
and what the other is doing that i am
also
a being like that but i think you can
also read here i think you can read
recognizes
in a double way it recognizes the other
for the first time
in a way that has been lacking it's been
misrecognizing the
other labeling the other as evil a label
that the other was willing to take on
insofar as there was some truth to it
but it's been holding itself to be the
beautiful soul
and now it's saying actually i'm not i'm
like the rest of you
so he says the forgiveness which it
extends
to the other is the renunciation of self
of its unreal essential being which
it put on a level with that other which
was a real action
and acknowledges that what thought
characterizes bad that is action is good
or rather it abandons this distinction
of the specific thought in its
subjectively determined judgment
so there's a lot going on there let's
unpack that
what is the universal consciousness
doing so he says that it's extending
forgiveness
to the other and i think we really
need to read the forgiveness here as
happening on both sides
but in different ways i think there's
also a forgiveness occurring on the side
of the individual consciousness who's
like
yeah you prick you finally get it don't
you
okay let's let's you know reconcile
let's acknowledge each other
but this forgiveness on the side of the
universal consciousness
which it should have given when the
acting consciousness first confessed and
it didn't give
is now being given and there's this is
taking place
through confession happening through
admission is another way we can say it
admission and acknowledgement
uh recognition of self and of other
takes place through these modes of
confession
and forgiveness at this point in the
phenomenology really late in the spirit
section
so he goes on and he says that um
this is a renunciation of its unreal
essential being which and he we could
insert here it wrongly put on a level
with that other
which was a real action right um
it it it was wrongly thinking that it
was better
than the acting consciousness it was
wrongly identifying itself as a
beautiful soul
now it's putting that aside and
also acknowledging hey i was a jerk by
pretending to be better than everybody
else
so it abandons this distinction of the
specific thought and it's subjectively
determined judgment
just as the other who's the other the
acting consciousness
abandons its subjective characterization
of action
and then here we have a really
interesting this
conclusion the word of reconciliation
is the now again miller's
is adding objectively we don't need
objectively in there
the existence the you know
zion is spirit which beholds the pure
knowledge of itself
as universal essence in its opposite
what would be the opposite of
it itself is universal essence in the
pure knowledge of itself
as absolutely self-contained and
exclusive individuality so now
both sides are grasping themselves as
both
universal and as individual
and they're grasping themselves as the
universal through
individuality and they're also
reciprocally
acknowledging or recognizing each other
as individuals within this universal
essentiality
you